[Musique]
ce que nous avons alors pensé était qu'au lieu d'
aller après le plastique, nous avons laissé le
plastique venir à nous en utilisant de très longues
barrières flottantes qui auraient dû
flotter pour laisser l'océan se
nettoyer en utilisant l'avantage net de Roshan Carson
chaque année des millions de tonnes de
le plastique pénètre dans les océans et se
concentre ensuite dans cinq zones du monde
appelées poubelles océaniques et la
plus grande d'entre elles est la tristement célèbre
Great Pacific Garbage Patch
[Music]
s'avère que nous pouvons réellement nettoyer 50%
de cette poubelle en seulement cinq  années
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]